when women go outside of a committed
relationship it's called betrayal when
men go outside of it it's called
cheating two different things okay
women can't go out and and just bang a
bunch of random guys and come back home
and pretend like they're still married
still in love still in a long-term
relationship when women cheat it's
because they want out there's no like
it's it's unquestionable they don't
cheat just for variety
some some people argue oh you know
there's polyamory and all sort of stuff
rubbish
if if a if a beautiful woman like he's
described here
goes outside of that relationship and
starts slamming kevin from sales it's
because she wants out of that
relationship and she's monkey branching
over
one of the stats i talked about in my
book is like more than fifty percent of
women admit to having a backup plan in a
marriage the other fifty percent won't
admit it but they probably do as well
right uh
it it requires deception and anything
that requires reception that makes a
woman look bad she's not going to be
likely to admit so just understand those
facts um
you may not agree with his life choices
or what he wants to do it doesn't mean
that it's wrong it might be wrong for
you because you don't have the options
if he's got the options and she's okay
with it what difference does it make to
you right like that's the point that i'm
trying to make is you can design your
life as you want as you see fit
another comment here from this guy says
i was literally that guy high value
foreigner in asia with a perfect
feminine girlfriend decided for monogamy
because she cried about it married her
when she was pregnant i found out she
had chad on the side for years when i
was out of town don't do my mistakes the
moment you go for monogamism is the
moment she lost respect for you make her
kids keep her busy women needs kids or
they start messing around it's in their
biological nature i don't totally agree
with everything that this guy's saying
um
the fact remains is that a woman wants a
guy that other women want
but they don't necessarily want him to
exercise those options there are women
that will be okay with him exercising
those options like i said
there's there's women with different
sets of beliefs just like there's guys
with different sets of beliefs there's
guys that you know believe certain
things like you have to worship her you
have to put her up on a pedestal and i'm
telling you guys don't do that chase
excellence not women right so everybody
has their own set of beliefs i just
wanted to break these down and kind of
go through them with you guys
to exemplify
some of the like foolish beliefs that a
lot of guys have that don't serve
these higher value established folks
again i mean like i'm looking at this
guy uh i click through it's got it's
it's a channel with one subscriber and
he watches a bunch of video games you
know is like he's like the content on
the like list
what does he do for a living i don't
know um whatever
uh time with ruby
okay so this is a okay so this next one
here is a chick
she says no woman is okay with cheating
[ __ ] uh cheating hurts emotionally
and mentally men are under the
impression women are okay with it
because she tolerates cheating there's a
difference if a woman is with you and
she's genuinely okay with you being
another woman she's not that into you
also [ __ ] there's lots and lots of
examples of women
and you know to my point earlier on
there's actually a good number of women
out there that are bi that want to bring
other girls into the relationship that
are even turned on strongly turned on by
you being with another girl
so saying that
um if a woman is with you and she's
generally okay with you being with other
women
she's saying she's not that into you
[ __ ]
uh she's most likely using you for your
money or she's passing time out of
boarding boredom not wanting to be alone
potentially also [ __ ] but there's
probably some truth to that as well uh
for the women who are in love with their
man who is cheating they are devastated
and they will put up with it to keep a
man happy
well you don't think men put up with
[ __ ] with women right like you know it's
like all about like this
solipsism like the whole world revolves
around this one head and it's like
there's no other universe outside of
that when it comes to that like men like
men make sacrifices and do things to
keep women happy too right so it's like
all about her all the time when you read
these comments for the women who love
their man but generally don't mind her
man being with other women are the
minority i wouldn't say the minority um
there's there's categorically a a group
of females and the demographics out
there that are okay with it they just
they just know right
one of the one of the common points that
a lot of guys make is like oh well would
you be okay with your daughter if she
was with a guy that was like you know
cheating on her sort of thing and i'd be
like look
my
my standards are the same across the
board okay if you're going to go out
there and you're a good looking gal
and you happen to come across the guy
that's
super high value very wealthy very well
connected he's captivating he's not
boring he's got a good social network he
does cool [ __ ] he's very good with frame
he knows how to game he's got high
status he looks stunning you know he's a
handsome fella he's got you know red
pill awareness all that stuff
you're gonna kind of have to accept the
fact that he's gonna have options and
he's probably gonna exercise those
options from time to time
it's a reality right
but the morons out there will say oh you
shouldn't accept that girl you should
break up with him
really is that is that always the best
solution is that your only solution is
that is that all you got because
this this shitty advice like this
foolish belief where it's like well just
dump them and find somebody that's loyal
i guarantee that if you ask
you know one of the things i um who did
i hear say this i think it was caleb
that that said this once he said
you know if a chick says that she
demands monogamy from you and you want
to be open on your end in the
relationship
ask her how many guys cheated on her you
know in the past
and
when you start doing this
and women out there you know you can
agree or disagree as a matter of me it's
it's factual
when you start doing this you're going
to come to realize that
most of the time if women are dating hot
dudes that are successful that have
their life together they've they're
going to be with other chicks you know
they're they're generally going to do
stuff like that um there's only a
handful of guys out there that will
choose let have the options but will
choose to be monogamous right um i've
done both i've done like whatever you
know like you can choose open on your
end you can choose monogamy whatever you
feel works for you
whatever you think is working for you at
that time choosing it let me keep
reading her a little statement over here
for the women who love her generally
okay
there's also no point in being in a
relationship for marriage if one person
doesn't have the discipline not to mess
around with other people while being in
a relationship with somebody you should
honestly like this chick would not care
if she was with an alpha chad that had
strong provisioning ability like she
lives in the um states obviously or
somewhere in you know the western world
this guy's probably like 300 000 usd and
southeast asia is probably the
equivalent of making i don't know
four or five million dollars a year in
the west
like
what do you bring to the table lady like
really like what are you doing because
again you know i i click through on it
the image is a picture of a cat i'm
assuming it's an older cat lady like
your advice and your opinion doesn't
really matter in a situation like this
because i don't know like what are you
doing with your life you're hanging out
with cats i i just you know
it happens though anyway let's go to
this next guy dude says this asian guy
has no idea how how hard it is to find a
perfect girl first of all there are no
perfect girls you spend
5 10 15 years with a check on a long
term basis you're going to find out how
imperfect she is over time how that
image of perfection i think this dude
was with this
girl for either 14 or 18 months but just
under two years
you're going to find out how imperfect
she is over time
anyway this guy is is praising the
unicorn
he is basically so lucky that he managed
to get her while she was young and
beautiful and still insecure and hasn't
crossed the whole rubicon and realized
with how much girls can get away with
these days a lot there's lots of women
out there that haven't crossed the whole
rubicon there really is and not just in
asia there's lots of women around the
world that that that don't subscribe to
promiscuity are they are they rarer than
the ones that subscribe to promise
security apps [ __ ] lutely yeah you
know it is you know it's true anyway i
know i sound like i'm putting on a
pedestal yeah you do dude you sound
exactly like you're putting her on a
pedestal um
she thinks she got really lucky and she
did more than you agree with richard's
advice to be honest i'm having a hard
time seeing a relationship succeed if
one partner is fully polyamorous all the
time i don't know really yes you really
don't know dude you don't know what
you're talking about um
on this email list you will have that
video come out with my talk with tristan
talking about in detail
some of the clarifying questions that i
want to get for that area of the book
that i'm writing on um it's it's not
coming out anytime soon guys are always
like is it gonna come out this summer no
it'll be out next year and it's gonna be
even better than than my first book so
stay tuned
hang tight man it's gonna come i'm a
slow writer um
okay and this next guy over here says
the guy answers his own question stay
single he's not ready for commitment
just let the girl know that i disagree
women can't be promuscus they certainly
can't
i said in the video dummy that women
can't be promiscuous without penalty
every time every guy that a woman's with
every new guy that she's with her smv
declines
okay a woman's value is based on women
are beauty objects to men
that's it we don't care about your
degrees we don't care about your cat
collections we don't give a [ __ ] about
your handbags and your dog or whatever
car you drive it's not as cool as mine
trust me we don't care about any of that
stuff women don't share their pot of
gold with men so what does that leave us
with women are beauty objects to men and
it's not my opinion it is the conclusive
summary of all the work of all these
guys in evil psych dr warren farrell
even talks about it at length as well
women are beauty objects to men slash
sex objects to men men are success
objects okay so when women become
promiscuous and they've run around the
block with a whole bunch of guys and
ladies don't think that you can get away
with it well okay let me rephrase that
don't think that we're not going to know
about it let's just put it that way
don't think that we have no idea
where you've been and what you've been
doing we know we're not [ __ ] stupid
okay um
i talk about it in some detail in my
book how to evaluate it but
it's it's not that hard
and
you're with 10 guys 20 guys 50 100 200
guys
over time
we just know how little value it is that
you bring to us um studies have been
done on female happiness depression
suicidal tendencies um instances of
single motherhood there's lots of data
on it i wish i had it ready for this
cast but
basically the more dudes a woman has
been with
the less likely she is to be happy the
more likely she is to be a single mother
the more likely she is to have stds the
more likely she is to be on
antidepressants and be depressed the
more likely she is to be single
like this list goes on and on the more
likely she is to divorce a guy if they
get married the more likely she is you
know
it just keeps going and going
um
so a woman can't be promiscuous
without consequences okay not to say
that they won't women run around today
all the time it's like what's good for
the goose is good for the gander if guys
can do it then i can do it too and this
is what they believe but guess what
you're gonna you're gonna pay the toll
you know you're gonna reap what you sow
you know it's as simple as that so
men on the other hand women don't care
about a guy's notch count they like they
it doesn't matter if it's 10 or 100 it
really doesn't matter
um sometimes they ask about it because
again what's good for the goose is good
for the gander and they try to figure
their [ __ ] out
but at the end of the day it's it's
really not a deciding factor for them
they just want it like women are more
concerned with a man's financial future
can this guy provide can he make it rain
if we need money right can he hunt and
gather whatever you know the narrative
might have been at that time
can this guy make make [ __ ] happen
that's what women are concerned with men
on the other hand because she's as
concerned with your financial future you
need to be concerned with her sexual
past what did she get up to who is she
with
you see what i'm saying because if
you're going to plan a future with her
to have kids with her then you have to
be certain that you're not dealing with
something that is going to create a
colossal train wreck in your life
the red flags that i talk about the tony
red flags you can get that chapter by
the way in that link below
this is another level this another guy
says this is another level you don't say
this stuff to women it should just be
understood ask me no questions and i'll
tell you no lies that's one angle is
just to be deceptive right there's lots
of dudes that are just totally you know
deceptive like i said earlier i've i've
talked to guys who wanted to open up
their marriage
and start to have some you know variety
on the side and they successfully did it
the vast majority of times they
successfully do it um you'd be surprised
you know you have a family you have a
woman that looks up to you
things change for women after kids
things change in relationships over time
again they just don't want to be
embarrassed they don't want some random
broad
knocking on her door being hey uh you
know is kevin there you know from the
sales team because this this kid over
here is uh his they don't want to be
embarrassed they don't want to deal you
know deal with [ __ ] like that so there's
some there's some basic rules that you
need to follow it's not complicated
uh we got a check here on this one she
says
women hate it when you call them checks
i find that so funny they always want to
police your language don't use that way
kick
i'm going to say whatever i want
so this chick says when a woman loves a
man we truly love them with all our
hearts this is true when
when a woman loves a guy other dudes are
invisible okay said that before we can't
imagine being with anyone else
absolutely true we want a good father
for our children which involves much
more than just money yes if he's okay
with cheating on her while she's at her
peak he'll do it throughout the marriage
if they go that route probably
each time he chiefs loosens the bond
between the two of them not true it's
better if he breaks up with her so she
can find someone better really she's
going to find someone better
this is this is where it starts to go
insane it's better if she breaks up with
him so she can find somebody better she
might find somebody that's monogamous
she might find somebody that's sexually
monogamous but she probably won't find
somebody that's sexually monogamous and
better than this dude
he's making the equivalent of a few
million dollars a year living in
southeast asia good looking guy
physically fit
socially influential not boring
captivating has a large social media
following a great network really that's
your advice leave the guy you'll find
somebody better
see this is the [ __ ] that gets flung
around so easily and then and then they
they end relationships like that right
over what
because he wanted to have some variety
one night hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you